we just had the winter olympics you are
one of the most
famous scotsman in the world i didn't
see a lot of scots
in the olympics i didn't i didn't see i
watched
and that's one thing i was thinking
about today pretty much everyone
represented am i right about that no no
the british team had four scottish guys
the curling team
the curl oh the curl i didn't watch the
curls the best sport in the world
the best sport in the world best sport
in the world really at last housework
has become olympic
they took a common chore and they made
it we're going to do it with vacuum
cleaners and they change their mind
it's extraordinary but the trouble with
it is that they've given it to young
people and they're all wearing spandex
and nylon and all that
curling is supposed to be played by
drunk people
wearing tweed yes it looks like that
kind of
hats woolly hats and you should have had
a few pints and then you should go out
a lot of drunk people on the ice
i went to a meeting a gathering called a
bonspiel in 1979
with 700 curlers on a lake yeah
it was bedlam the noise was unbelievable
so i hadn't marked out the lanes or
anything they just
people getting knocked over like nine
pins so they hadn't actually there was
no real
you couldn't even possibly play in those
conditions absolutely people singing and
getting drunk
it was wonderful that's what you think
the olympics should be
it's called a sport it's a sport now how
come they can have winter olympics
without a snowball fight
you think that's how it should end the
building of a snowman it's
good sports they should make it more fun
like that absolutely
it should take the piss out of it a
little bit delusion the luge doubles was
very interesting
did you like that yeah people lying and
talking each other
you like that huh yeah
you can't lift your head because you
slow down it's good what are you doing
dude
it's a change in my pocket yeah right
[Laughter]
now uh speaking of drinking you've been
sober for
a while now what years how many years
30. 30 years you've been sober
what is it and what's in hell
what is it that caused you what was the
event that caused you from not being too
personal to stop drinking
well there were many reasons but the
main one was
that dawned on me that alcohol doesn't
make you clever
one night i was drinking with a friend
of mine peter mcdougall a writer
and i left his house blitzed and i
went to phone home to my wife and i get
into one of those british telephone
boxes
you know those red ones yeah and i made
my
phone then i realized i couldn't get out
[Laughter]
you were you couldn't you didn't you
couldn't figure out i couldn't figure it
out you know there was nothing wrong
with the box the door was working fine
i mean the telephone's on one of the
walls that cuts it down to three
[Music]
and it's hardly hampton court maze
so what did you do i phoned my manager
yeah
and i ran out of money and hey steve i'm
stuck
with our years
and he found me he just went he went and
looked at every phone booth he could
find
unless i was on a street called
he went to all my usual haunts and he
phoned me and he just opened the door
for you
smelling of urine i hadn't peed but a
lot of people pee in those boxes
oh it wasn't even your urine
oh that's the worst nothing worse than
smelling of someone else
you